[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
للسحب حركه تبعا لحركه الرياح
الدافعه لها وللنجوم حركه تبعا لدوران
الارض حول نفسها ودورانها حول الشمس
ونتيجه لهذا تتكون الفصول والمواسم وهذه
الفصول سحبها لها اتجاه يا غربيه يا شرقيه
الغربيه ماطره الشرقيه عابره والعابره
تكون حركتها بطيئه ومنفرشه وكاتمه للاجواء
وهذا يكون في عز القيض واحب اذكركم مهنا
لنا حركه تبعا لحركه الايام لنا دع الايام
تفعل ما تشاء وطب نفسا اذا حكم القضاء ولا
تجزع لحادثه الليالي فما لحوادث الدنيا
بقائه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ومع دخولي موسم الوسم من شهر اكتوبر وطالع
تبدا تاتين السحب من الجهه الغربيه
كتخريجات بحريه من البحر الاحمر او
مستورده من هضبه البحيرات هو البحر الابيض
المتوسط ومع دخول مربعانيه البيض تبدا
تاتينا من الجهه الشرقيه كتخريجات بحريه
من الخليج العربي او مستورده من بحر العرب
وما بين الصيف والشتاء تكون متخلخله في
حركتها وليس لها وجه وما الحزن في وجه
الفتاه شرفا له اذا لم يكن في فعله
والخلائقي
[موسيقى]